love your city man my first time there
and we were very much
in the uh hood
yeah we was around bro yeah yeah it get
like that man but honestly bro i felt i
i didn't you know i feel like uh
coming away from that trip i was like
man i feel like detroit has a bad uh nat
like like reputation yeah everybody
everybody thinks like if you come to
detroit we gonna do this right
really detroit man we love everybody bro
long as you ain't on that [ __ ] or
disrespecting the city then we ain't got
nothing we ain't got no problem with you
what's one thing about detroit too like
all these other cities like
everybody separate you know what i'm
saying but like in detroit like even if
we is separate the moment you do some
[ __ ] the one important person in
that city we're gonna all come together
on your head now one thing about these
tricks they're gonna stick together on
your head right i just saw uh rest in
peace the hutch right yeah that's the
jeweler and and uh just did any piece i
ever got in my life
he uh got someone shot him right it was
just kind of random what happened yeah i
don't know the story behind that [ __ ]
but this is it's [ __ ] up because it's
like everybody go to hutch no matter who
don't know hutch was a big jeweler and
big jewels kind of like the jeweler
right the number one jeweler in detroit
ain't nobody [ __ ] the hutch like he's
the number one jewel
like i used to be in high school like
man when i'm doing what the [ __ ] i'm
doing like [ __ ] when i get some money
[ __ ] that's what i'm going to [ __ ]
hutch like you're going to get your bus
from hutch you're going to get your
chain from her and here he's a lovely
dude man he show love and respect man he
loved the city i love the city so the
city just took a big loss with that [ __ ]
i noticed everyone was posting them yeah
man [ __ ] [ __ ] up about that one yeah
it's it's so like because we always hear
about like this big divide between the
east side and the west side of detroit
yeah um
how much of that is
real and how much of it is like a little
actually it's actually back in the day
it was bigger you know what i'm saying
you really couldn't get the east side
and west side [ __ ] to [ __ ] with each
other like by any means now
we all [ __ ] with each other like me
the east side i'm a west side [ __ ]
eastside showed me so much [ __ ]
love you think i was like from the east
like my [ __ ] lou vez peasy danny [ __ ]
man let's go on with them eastside boys
man and they face ray like they are
taking over right now too so it's like
they putting on for the city too so now
it's like we all understanding the
assignment and we coming together and
[ __ ] understanding like it's not no
real beef now if you got real beef
behind that [ __ ] then people leave that
alone but it's like if it's some she he
say she say or [ __ ] [ __ ] yo [ __ ] [ __ ]
man we looking over that man come on man
[ __ ] that [ __ ] we better make this hit
song and we're going to stun on that hoe
because it does feel like right now the
east side has a lot of the big more
bigger artists nationally but i felt i
feel like uh early on like if we think
about uh you know boys
those are all west side guys so i feel
like it kind of and and i was talking to
uh i forget who was telling me
that the west side is more
like the player [ __ ] i gave it to you a
breakdown westside
west side [ __ ] you have some of the
west side west side is more flashy
meaning as in
and it is it's different now because we
everybody getting everybody's getting
money saying
back then it'd be like a west side [ __ ]
go spend all that money on this outfit
to look good for the hoes and go out
that day but don't it's broke as [ __ ]
right that eastside [ __ ] gonna have
that that jargon shoot on looking dirty
as hell with that bankroll [ __ ] hustle
you know what i'm saying eastside i got
a lot of hustler [ __ ] both sides got
the hustle in it but now it's like we
all just get into the paper nah